this is a story of Robert smalls a man
who was born a slave and went on to hold
one of the highest positions in
government and become a hero of the
Civil War Robert smalls was born into
slavery in South Carolina back then if a
slave had enough money they could
literally buy their freedom but smalls
wanted to buy the freedom of his whole
family a price that was more than he
could afford in 1852 while working close
to more than lines on a Confederate boat
called the CSS planter smalls hatched a
plan one night when the white officers
left the ship smalls is left in charge
with no time to spare smalls took over
the ship rounded up the other slaves and
their families and set sails for Union
waters but smalls and his crew would
have to pass through for Confederate
checkpoints before they would be free
smalls disguised himself by wearing the
captain's jacket and straw hat and
mimicking his gait having worked on the
CSS planter for years he knew all of the
hand signals used by Confederate sailors
to pasture checkpoints the boat passed
one two and three checkpoint at the
final point which was also the most
heavily armed
smalls flashes signal and got the
go-ahead and just like that Robert
smalls and his family literally sailed
to freedom towards the end of his life
smalls returned to the house in which he
was born a slave buying it outright from
his former slave master to live out his
days a man who went from slave to one of
the most prominent figures in America